five at six
this is eight news now have you had
anything to drink
you know you taking any prescription
meds or anything
you don't take any prescription meds
no
did you take anything today
no that is nevada highway patrol
investigating one of our state's
deadliest crashes it was in december of
last year a truck driver plowed into a
group of cyclists on the 95 right near
search like killing five so now after a
month's long investigation the i-team
confirms troopers did not suspect that
driver was impaired our i-team's david
charns here with why that affected this
whole case david well jordan barson was
high on meth so much a toxicologist
wrote the amount in his blood is often
seen in overdoses but that critical
element to this whole dui case was
discovered without a warrant
i don't have reason to believe he's
under influence but
he's obviously just wrong it's just one
of the many times nevada highway patrol
troopers say they don't think a driver
who had just killed five cyclists was
impaired i didn't smell anything though
i think he's just destroyed aces
troopers didn't smell anything because
jordan barson wasn't impaired from
alcohol a blood test would show enough
methamphetamine in his system to
overdose i don't smell anything on him
but we need to track him for 55.
it's around 10 a.m on december 10 20 20.
over the course of 50 minutes troopers
wearing their body cameras document
every piece of pavement among metal and
pieces of bikes strewn across u.s 95
five white sheets marked the dead his
pure joy
was just being out there on a beautiful
day riding his bike donna trauger's
husband tom was among the victims
one of the things i'm really grateful
for is that i was awake that morning
that
we talked and
that i got to see him before he left for
his ride 57 year old tom trauger had
joined the planned 130 mile long trek to
celebrate another rider was retiring a
second had a birthday
not soon after the crash that thursday
morning donna answered a facebook
message it was another rider asking her
to call
he started crying and he just said i'm
really sorry and i started crying and i
said
please just say it just tell me and he
said
tom was killed but it would be hours
before she knew for sure tom trauger
wore a gps watch in the event of an
emergency i got
a text message from garmin
with tom's gps coordinates because i was
his emergency contact those coordinates
said tom
was at the clark county coroner's office
as troopers worked to identify the dead
they also worked on the living have you
had anything to drink
are you taking any prescription meds or
anything
you don't take any prescription meds
no
did you take anything today no they're
trying to convince barson to submit to a
voluntary blood draw and their window is
closing one of the things that happened
would you possibly get your driver's
license system one of the things to
think about i know is a lot the process
if barson didn't agree a judge would
have to sign off on a warrant it's not a
matter of us suspecting impairment
do you understand where i'm coming from
minutes earlier a trooper put barson
through a standard field sobriety test
as barson was going through the motions
another trooper looking on says this
this report saying the trooper would
ultimately deem the results
unsatisfactory
as barson was quote shaking
uncontrollably and was an emotional
wreck and because they didn't suspect
impairment troopers then sent jordan
barson on his way back to arizona that
day in 15 minutes we'll show you what
happened next i'm david charns live
local now
now this is eight news now live at 6 30
live local now and thank you for staying
with us at 6 30. i'm denise valdez and
i'm bryan loftis nhp troopers didn't
suspect impairment in a driver who had
just killed five cyclists on a straight
road on a clear day rit's david charns
continuing his investigation with what
troopers missed david a blood test would
show jordan barson had enough meth in
his system to overdose but nobody at
that crash site knew that or picked up a
phone to call a judge and without
suspecting impairment troopers need
barson to agree to a voluntary blood
draw here's how they got it
i don't have reason to believe he's
under influence but
he's obviously just wrong it's just one
of the many times nevada highway patrol
troopers say they don't think a driver
who had just killed five cyclists was
impaired
i didn't smell anything though i think
he's just destroyed he's i mean
obviously what happened
nevada highway patrol troopers
investigating one of the deadliest
crashes in years didn't smell anything
because jordan barson wasn't impaired
from alcohol he had as much
methamphetamine in his system as is
often seen in overdose victims just
yards from where body cameras roll five
cyclists lie dead in the road
will you volunteer and cooperate with
that will you volunteer for the blood
draw with impairment not suspected
troopers are trying to convince barson
to submit to a voluntary blood draw i
think about what i was talking to about
giving us a voluntary all right
at this point we just need to know yes
or no in all troopers ask barson if
he'll consent five times
this is how the trooper wrote about
those times in his report
after a while i asked him if he would
submit to a blood draw he said that he
would provide a blood sample nevada
highway patrol they didn't they didn't
get a search warrant in the case and
that had to do with they didn't suspect
dui former deputy district attorney
thomas maskel was the lead prosecutor on
the case ultimately
that had
negative consequences for down the road
because this became a huge dui case a
case leading to five counts of dui
resulting in death
marson ended up pleading guilty to two a
judge sentencing him to 16 to 40 years
in prison
moscow simply saying nhp didn't do its
job
victim blaming
i mean
it was offensive you know nevada highway
patrol got there and immediately
the cyclists are in the middle of the
road he points to this it's when the
troopers realized the cyclists were
riding in the right lane or the number
two they were in the number two
yeah they were writing in the number two
but the nevada department of
transportation says cyclists are allowed
to ride on this rural section of u.s 95
there is no rule barring them from the
right lane they were allowed to be there
in the road but even if they weren't
i don't see how when five cyclists get
killed too seriously injured
that an investigator at the scene says
oh they were in the they were in the
road at 10 am on a brightly lit day
and somehow
this is not not a criminal act anymore
it's not a matter of us suspecting
impairment
do you understand where i'm coming from
moscow is critical of those comments
where he says the troopers seemingly try
to convince barson to give in even
though he had just killed five people on
a clear day on a straight road they
never called a judge the blood with the
methamphetamine would never make it to
the jury two weeks after barson's blood
results came back showing he had nine
times the limit of meth in his blood for
what prosecutors need to file charges an
nhp drug recognition expert filed her
report based on what she saw in the
videos his performance on the
standardized field sobriety tests showed
numerous clues of impairment
we don't expect any signs of impairment
the trooper adding i observed no signs
or indication of a person who was tired
and mr barson was under the influence of
a stimulant it's obvious to me
and i'm not even trained nearly a year
after jordan barson killed her husband
donna trauger says she has never heard
from nhp jordan barson is in prison for
two deaths not five he's certainly
serving time for the crime that he
committed
but he is not serving
the correct sentence
for the crimes that he committed
and that's because
the troopers didn't do their jobs that
day
it reminds her to do something tom used
to tell her often he would say let it go
if i had a dollar for every time he said
let it go to me i'd be very rich
but
i can't let this one go
not this one
nhp in the department of public safety
which oversees the agency declined
several on-camera interview requests but
they did send me a statement and it says
this
these crashes can be avoided if drivers
make smart decisions and they go on to
say that they have reviewed this
investigation and are improving
techniques and training when we ask how
nhp is doing that and what changes have
been made i did not get a response i'm
david charns live local now